só os filmes mais um vídeo e hoje vou
fazer uma coisa diferente aqui no canal
porque 1 mil vai capacitar os dias a
minha casa então eu saiba fazer uma
coisa bem divertida então hoje eu vou
ensinar um jogo que você consegue cruzar
as águas nero e vocês não tiverem armas
não podem fazer o mesmo jogo das armas
que disparam las e que o kinect aquilo
que era para os garis vamos tomar as
duas é o que eu tenho aqui começa com 30
copos do kabuscorp mente do jogo por
água ou então bonitão e coque sobrarem
vai resolver a vida que vocês vão ter
como o jogo contato com os meus amigos
com ela é muito importante o jogo a duas
bolas no jogo
fruto de mais uma quebra e com maior
primário usar o mesmo tom e crosby ou
porque o denunciar um novato e agora
essa porta de um esbarrão
[Música]
mas fazer distribuição de skópelos
batalha e vamos distribuir os forma que
o adversário consiga acertar nelson a
proteção e e vamos pensar duas vezes no
passado
[Música]
aí muda de rota
não
[Música]
o exame portuguesa
eu só para tirar vantagens para que o
estado diga nos comentários que estarão
mais etapa ver mais detalhes destas